It's me Destin, and I finally met somebody stranger than me
He's really really strange
He's kinda got at the left brain right brain
thing like that going on as well
Hi, I'm Josh Bateman
Today I'm gonna, I'm gonna do a little
bit of fine art
It's coming along, we just had to take a break and
shoot bigger guns
Construction art
As you can see
in previous video yeah we
created these things and you'd like one
get in contact with destin or contact
with me my website should be up soon
redefiningtheartist.com if you to
purchase one of these
let me know, as well if you want comission
in a different work.
I know how to shoot stuff
I just hate ending videos
'Cause it's at the very end, you know
so you've done all this work and then
you realize
where don't know how to end
I'll see you all later